Major major breaking news as Pam Bondi,
the attorney general for President
Trump, has been fired. Is this good for
the Second Amendment or bad for the
Second Amendment? Or maybe a little bit
of both. We need to break down this in
extreme detail in a professional way,
folks, because there's some risk to the
loss of Pam Bondi. But maybe there's
some additional hope as well. We're
going to have to get geeky on this and
be pros when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of donor, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All
right, folks. This is huge news.
Attorney General Pam Bonnie has been
fired by President Donald J. Trump.
There's a lot of rumors as to why she
was fired. I'm not going to report on
those cuz I going to let other networks
do that, if you will. But the question
we have now is what do we in the second
amendment community think about the
firing of Pam Bunny? Should we be happy?
Should we be sad? Should we be worried?
Should we we ecstatic?
Well, I think it's a little bit of all
of the above. So, let's first of all,
let's go over some of the great things
that Pam Bondi did and then let's go
over some of the problems that she had
and then let's discuss moving forward.
But let me give you the answer. My
ultimate answer is this. Overall, Pam
Bonnie was extremely good for the Second
Amendment. The things that she did were
things we've never seen done before by
in the history of this country by the
United States Department of Justice,
such as, for example, creating a Second
Amendment working group. We'll get to
that in a moment. But with that said,
with that said, there is definitely some
very specific room for improvement.
there are specific areas that must be
improved by the next attorney general
and we're going to lay that out in
detail when we get to that in just a
moment. So to begin with, let's take a
look at attorney general Pam Bonnie's
record when it comes to the Second
Amendment. Overall, it's excellent.
Overall, it's very good as the attorney
general. She is the best attorney
general in American history when it
comes to the Second Amendment. Period.
Okay, that's not BS. That's factual. And
why do I say that? And by the way, I'm
only talking about American history over
the last 50, 60 years because prior to
that time, we didn't really have to
worry about a bunch of insane gun
control brought about by foreignb born
individuals and billionaires that want
to destroy America. This is a recent
phenomenon that has really occurred
really in the last 50 to 60 years. So,
we have to compare Pam Bonnie as the
attorney general to other attorney
generals in the last 50 60 years because
I don't really think comparing them to
what happened in the 19th century is
really analogous. With that said, Pam
Bonnie's Attorney General's office and
the Department of Justice has done
excellent on the Second Amendment in the
following ways. Number one is at the
direction of President Trump with an
executive order. They created a Second
Amendment working group to laser focus
on improving and expanding and
protecting our right to keep arms.
That's very good. Number two, for the
first time in American history, we've
seen the Department of Justice actually
file amikas briefs in cases involving
state gun control laws supporting the
Second Amendment. Not only that, we've
actually seen Harmy Dylan, the head of
the civil rights division, literally go
to the United States Court of Appeals
for the Seventh Circuit in Chicago and
argue on behalf of the Second Amendment
in a quote unquote assault weapon case.
We also saw their mikas briefs in
support of suppressors, large so-called
large capacity magazines, which are
really standard capacity magazines, and
semi-automatic rifle bands in New
Jersey. For example, in the brief that
the DOJ under Pam Bonnie filed in the
Cheeseman and the Association New Jersey
Rifle and Pistol Clubs cases out there
in the US Court of Appeals for the third
circuit on bond. We also know that this
Pam Bonnie Department of Justice has
brought a series of lawsuits involving
the undue delays and undue cost
associated with various licensing
departments in various parts of the
United States, including out there in
California. And of course, we know just
we've been reporting on this just today,
uh, there in the District of Columbia,
not only has the Pam Bondi Department of
Justice, thanks to Janine Piro, the US
attorney for DC, brought lawsuits
against the District of Columbia's bans
on semi-automatic rifles, AR-15s,
AK-47s. But we also see that the Pam
Bondi Department of Justice with Jannine
Piro uh stood up and helped us win that
Benson case which of course was the huge
decision that creates a split of
authority uh 2 to1 in that Benson versus
DC case involving so-called large
capacity magazines banned by of course
uh District of Columbia and of course we
saw very powerful pro-second amendment
briefs for example in the Wolford case
which is the so-called vampire rule case
arising out of Hawaii uh the Pam Bonnie
Department of justice filed a powerful
mikas brief and actually had Sarah
Harris of the solicister general's
office argue alongside the private
attorney Alan Beck in the Wolfford case
arguing that indeed the Hawaii law
violated the second amendment.
Everything I just described is something
that has literally never occurred before
in American history when it comes to a
department of justice standing up and
fighting for our second amendment
rights. So on that basis, there is no
doubt it is accurate to say that Pam
Bonnie's tenure as attorney general of
the United States is the best we've ever
seen when it comes to advancing and
protecting our Second Amendment right to
keep arms. Period. And obviously there's
her people have helped her tremendously.
Har Dylan, the head of the civil rights
office, Janine Peril, the US attorney
for the District of Columbia, you know,
members of the solicister general's
office, including Sarah Harris, have all
done an excellent job in our favor.
Okay, so that's very, very good. And the
fact that we've lost Pam Bondi is
potentially a negative because there is
no guarantee that whoever gets picked
next will be better than what I've just
described. Okay, with that said, there
is room for improvement. Okay, now I
know some people out there think all I
do is say Pam Bonnie is the greatest
thing ever. And again, for the record
that I've just articulated, she is. That
does not mean there's not room for
improvement. And I made this clear sort
of in some videos and in other contexts.
There is definitely room for
improvement. And let me tell you
specifically
the areas of improvement that we need to
see in the next attorney general that
that Pam Bonnie was not strong on. And
that is this mission critical to
understand this folks. This is going to
make you a pro.
The Solicitor General's Office of the
United States, which is the office that
represents the federal government before
the US Supreme Court, needs to be
reigned in and fixed.
John Sour, the solicitor general, is
very good and has done some very good
things for the Trump administration and
very good things for America and even
some good things when it comes to the
Second Amendment. However, the Solicitor
General's office of the United States,
which does represent the US sup the US
government in front of the Supreme
Court, has not been great, has been
good, but not great on the Second
Amendment. And they've made some, in my
view, terrible strategic blunders. They
did it on purpose, and that's no good.
And what do I mean by this? The
solicitor general's office is primarily
responsible for deciding which cases
they seek certain
to the Supreme Court and positions they
take before the Supreme Court and in the
federal appellet courts.
Now you know and I know and this has
made this very clear. I think I first
brought this up publicly at an event for
the Gun Owners of America last summer
where I flagged this as a potential
issue before this was even a case. I
said unequivocally that the solicitor
general's office which is under the
Department of Justice and specifically
the solicitor general's office, the
solicitor general is the number four
person in terms of the hierarchy at the
Department of Justice. The person that
runs the Department of Justice is the
president, of course, but below the
president, you have the attorney general
of the United States, which is Pam
Bondi, the deputy attorney general,
which is Todd Blanch, and then an
associate attorney general, and then you
have the solicitor general. If the
solicitor general is going to do
something stupid or problematic
strategically from the Second Amendment
point of view, someone above the
solicitor general needs to pick up the
phone, call him up, and tell him, "No,
stop. Do not do this. You're not
allowed. You're below me. Do what I
say." Pam Bondi did not do that. And I
do fault her for this. Now, in fairness,
I think that some of the legal issues
that we deal with on this channel might
be, let's just politely, might be a bit
more sophisticated than the kind of
legal considerations that Pam Bonnie has
historically had to deal with. So, with
that said, I do understand to some
degree Pam Bonnie's probable, I'm
guessing this is the case. I don't have
inside information, but I'm guessing
that Pam Bonnie's deference for the
solicitor general's office was because
she felt they knew better than what she
knew.
But whatever it was, the solicitor
general's office when it comes to Second
Amendment decision-making has to be
reigned in and fixed. Why do I say that?
Number one, there's a case they brought
to the Supreme Court, which is insane.
Why on earth, if you support the Second
Amendment, does this Department of
Justice push to the Supreme Court and
seek certain
versus United States case? Hammani was
an individual who of course admitted to
using marijuana and was convicted of
using marijuana while possessing
firearms. He also on the record admitted
to being a cocaine user. He also had
connections allegedly to the Iranian
revolutionary guard and all sorts of
other terror terrible connections like
to drug dealing and to terrorism.
Why on earth if you support the second
amendment do you want to push the hmani
case to the supreme court and have sh be
granted in a 922g prohibited person case
and have that be the fact pattern?
Literally every high school kid in
America knows that bad facts made bad
law, good facts make good law. So the
fact that Pam Bonnie is the attorney
general did not pick up the phone and
tell the solicitor general, you are not
bringing the Hmani case to the Supreme
Court, that's absurd. That is the sort
of thing I would expect out of Joe Bine
and Merrick Garland's Department of
Justice, which is what they did in the
Raheem case involving the individual
that took his girlfriend's head, bash it
against the dashboard, and then shot at
witnesses. That's the 922G prohibited
person federal case. I would expect the
mayor Garland and Joe Biden of the road
to push to the Supreme Court. But why on
earth is u John Sour and the solister
general doing that with Hammani when
you're supposed to be pro- second
amendment? Someone needed to pick up the
phone and tell John Sauer, you are not
doing this and I'm not letting you do
it. Pam Bonnie did not do that and that
was a mistake and that needs to get
fixed the next time the next attorney
general we have they will pick up the
phone and have the uh gumption if you
will to stop the SG from making bad
mistakes. But it gets worse from my
point of view with the solicitor
general's office because while pushing
to the Supreme Court the Hmani case,
what are the two cases the solicitor
general's office chose not to bring to
the Supreme Court, not to seek certain
and polo Windsor, meaning to flip sides
on? Well, that would be the Reese case
out of the US Court of Appeals for the
Fifth Circuit that said that 18, 19, and
20 year olds have full-blown Second
Amendment rights on a very sympathetic p
fact pattern and very nicely laid out
opinion by several judges down there in
the US Court of Appeals for the Fifth
Circuit covering Louisiana, Texas, and
Mississippi.
No, the solicitor general's office is
like, why would I bring a case like Ree,
which is beautifully laid out and can
establish once and for all that 18, 19,
and 20 year olds have full-blown Second
Amendment rights. No, instead they chose
not to seek cert in the Ree case and
just roll it over and let it be, which
is good for if you're 18, 19 or 20 year
olds in those three states. That's a
positive, but why would you push that
case to the Supreme Court instead of
Hammani? Hello. You only, you know, at
the solicitor general's office there,
the Supreme Court's only going to take
one or two Second Amendment cases a
term. And you make a decision to push a
guy connected to the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard or whatever they're
calling over there who's a drug dealer
and does drugs who you know that Samo
and Roberts don't like drug people,
right? You know that. And yet you do it
anyway. The the attorney general of the
United States, Pam Money, should have
called up John Sour and stopped it. They
didn't. But now again, they did not push
Reese. And likewise, if you want to deal
with a 922G case, and as you know, 18
USC 922G is the federal statute defined
as or defines who are prohibited people
who are not allowed to possess firearms.
And there's a whole list of those,
right? Whole list of these 922G
categories. And John Sar decides he's
going to push to the Supreme Court the
Hammmani case on a terrible set of
facts. When what did he have available
to him? Oh, I don't know. We had the
Brian Range case that had won in favor
of the Second Amendment in the United
States Court of Appeals for the Third
Circuit with guys on that court like
Judge Bibbis, Judge Porter, Judge
Hardman
among others. Powerful people, powerful
intellectuals. Everyone on the Supreme
Court knows these people and respects
these people. And you, John Sour, the
solicitor general, choose not to seek
cert in the Brian Range case, where
Brian Range is the most sympathetic fact
pattern you could ever imagine or draw
up involving a gun ban for life in a
922G context where like three decades
ago, 30 years ago, in his 20s or
something, Brian Range and his wife got,
you know, in some sort of kurluffle over
alleged food stamp fraud or something
where he failed to report some
lawnmowing income and therefore became a
felony. because the technical
misdemeanor he was convicted of under
Pennsylvania law at the time had like a
potent potential 5-year prison sentence.
Of course, Brian Range didn't serve a
day because there was no reason to think
so. And why did John Sarah the solicitor
general's office not push the Brian
Range case to the Supreme Court and
instead chose to push Hammani? Another
example where a strong attorney general
could have picked up the phone and says,
"You got this all wrong." So again, Pam
Bonnie did a very good job. historically
great job on the Second Amendment, but
there is room for improvement. And the
single most important, listen to me
carefully. You Second Amendment
influencers out there, you authors out
there, all the people that are involved
with this process, if you watch this
video at any point, let me be extremely
clear and unambiguous. The single most
important thing we need from the next
attorney general in addition to of
course being strong on the second
amendment with all the typical
bonafites. Don't be a democrat. Don't be
a career prosecutor. Any of those things
that are red flags in my opinion for
being good on the second amendment.
Don't do any of that. Assuming you got
all those other qualifications met and
criteria met. The single most important
thing that the next attorney general for
Donald Trump needs to do is he needs to
be able to pick up the phone and have
the gumption to tell the solicitors
general's office. Do not bring stupid
cases to the Supreme Court on bad fact
patterns ever again. No matter what your
career prosecutors who like to win for
the government, no matter what they say,
you need to override that and make sure
they bring good cases to the Supreme
Court to establish great precedent.
Because unlike changing an ATF
regulation in our favor, which is great,
the reality is a powerful constitutional
president by a Supreme Court decision
will last potentially generations and is
far more valuable than again, you know,
changing uh a 4473 form or something at
FFL. As much as that's important in the
grand scheme of things, Supreme Court
victories for the Second Amendment are
the most important things that we should
be shooting for. and the solicitor
general's office is doing a okay job but
not a great job and most importantly the
attorney general needs to be able to
pick up the phone and tell John Sar and
the solicitor general's office what to
do moving forward when it comes to the
second amendment that is the area of
improvement that is exactly where Pam
Bonnie fell down when it comes to the
second amendment rights that's the
specific criticism and again people will
quote comments she made as the attorney
general of Florida I don't care about
any of that question is what did she do
as the attorney general of the United
States and there's a lot of great things
she did but again the specific area of
room for improvement is critical and I
should also note the other problem that
the solicitor general's office and I
have it based on people I've talked to
the solicitor general's office is also
the problem when it comes to these
remedy problems associated with not
entering to proper consent decrees in
favor of the second amendment not you
know getting the scope of relief proper
because they're worried and I understand
why they're worried they're worried
about you know anti-Trump lawfare going
on with the scope of relief in terms of
like, you know, universal injunctions
and they're worried about that. But all
that is being pushed down from the
solicitor general's office and above.
And again, this is the sort of thing
that the next attorney general should be
able to say, "Why are you not settling
these gun own gun owner of America's
cases or the Second Amendment Foundation
cases or or the California Rifle and
Pistol Association cases?" Or, "Why are
you not settling uh the Firearms Policy
Coalition cases or whatever it is in a
favorable way with a consent decree that
will last for years to come? Why are you
messing around with these things? Why
are you not doing the right thing?" And
I suspect a lot of that is being coming
down from the SG's office and other
parts of the DOJ that are focused on
winning for the federal government and
not winning for the Second Amendment and
not winning for Second Amendment
organizations and not winning for people
that want to exercise their Second
Amendment rights. And again, as to who
it should be, um, we can talk about
this. I do not think I 100% do not think
it should be Harmy Dylan as great as she
would be. Why? Because I do not want
Harmy Dylan and all of the excellent
work she's being doing to get diffused.
I don't want her to spend 70% of her
day, you know, worrying about the
prosecution and the death penalty of
drug dealers and things like this. I
don't want her being taken away from
that very focused mission on advancing
American civil rights. So, I do not
think she's the right person for this.
Not because she wouldn't be great at it,
because I don't want her distracted with
other issues that you have to deal with
like the Epstein files that'll suck up,
you know, weeks and weeks on of your
life if you're the attorney general in
today's environment or whatever that is.
Um, I certainly there is very strong
evidence and and reason to think that
Lee Zeldon might be a very good attorney
general. He really took on the
environmentalist when overturning the
so-called endangerment finding that said
CO2 the things that you know we exhale
is a pollutant. He overturned that
endangerment finding which is hugely
important for America and the economy
and obviously buck the bureaucrats. So
there might be a very strong case that
Lee Zelden should be the next attorney
general and would have the uh you know
sort of have this force of will if you
will to reign in the solister general
office with the second amendment issues
and he has gotten very good ratings when
it comes to uh second amendment record
in the past uh there. But again, you
know, we'll have to see how it goes.
We'll talk about that if we need to. But
in the meantime, uh we have to give
credit where credit's due. Pam Bonnie
did a great job in many respects. Uh,
but there's room for improvement and
let's try to improve and definitely make
sure we don't go backwards with the next
selection of the attorney general. I
know what I'm going to be focused on.
What I articulate in this video is
exactly what I'm going to be looking
for. It's a little bit nerdy. It's a
little inside Washington, a little
inside bellway stuff, but to make you
the smartest person in the room, this is
what you need to understand and not just
mouthing shall not be infringed or Pam
Bonnie is blah blah blah. You need to
actually be able to articulate the
problems with her and how to fix it
moving forward to be the best person and
the smartest person when it comes to our
second amendment rights. All right,
folks. Hope you enjoyed today's episode.
Make sure you follow me on x4box. Don't
forget to subscribe both the YouTube and
Rumble and I'll talk to you again real
soon here at the warboxes.com.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.